un golpe contra los oligarcas rusos el
reino unido- incluyó siete empresarios
entre sus sancionados los de más alto
nivel en incluirse en esta lista se nos
acusa de ser cercanos al presidente
vladimir putin a todos se les prohíbe
viajar hacia territorio británico y se
congela en sus activos entre ellos
figuran roman abramovich que pretendía
vender al chelsea evaluado en unos 3.200
millones de dólares ahora no sólo esa
transacción queda congelada sino
cualquier movimiento comercial del club
eso sí podrán seguir compitiendo en la
premier league gracias a una licencia
especial a brand abramovich tiene
vínculos con putin que es quien está
montando un ataque bárbaro a malvado
contra el pueblo de ucrania este
gobierno nosotros en este departamento
estamos con el pueblo de ucrania y como
he dicho me temo que las sanciones
tienen consecuencias las acciones de
abramovich también tienen consecuencias
y los otros seis sancionados ya habían
sido incluidos en las listas de la unión
europea o estados unidos sus fortunas
acumulan 19 mil 740 millones de dólares
destacan 'el directores el gigante
petrolero ruso rosneft igor sechín y el
magnate de la metalurgia o lecter y
pascal canciones que para los
detractores del premier boris johnson
llegan de manera tardía en medio de
críticas por los más de 2 millones y
medio de dólares que su partido el
conservador ha recibido de donantes
rusos